[Musique]
bonjour merci de suivre ses campagnes
régionales et départementales sur tv
60,18 le 7-8 politique que reviendra
aujourd'hui sur la situation dans les
cantons yvelinois à montigny le
bretonneux à bonnières sur seine ou
encore à maurepas à côté régional vous
entendrez à valérie pécresse à propos de
son programme pour l'île de france
en attendant comment se déroule le
scrutin régional justement nous nous
étions penchés récemment sur le vote des
départementales voici les explications
pour l'autre rendez vous qui attend les
électeurs elle les 20 et 27 juin
explications signé célia 400 go les
élections régionales ont lieu tous les
six ans selon un mode de scrutin
proportionnel de liste à deux tours avec
prime majoritaire c'est à dire que si
une liste obtient plus de 50% des
suffrages exprimés
elle obtient immédiatement un quart des
sièges disponibles
les autres sièges sont répartis
proportionnellement entre toutes les
listes qui ont obtenu au moins 5% des
suffrages exprimés dans ce cas là il n'y
a qu'un seul tour de scrutin
mais si aucune liste n'obtient la
majorité absolue un second tour est
organisé pour y participer une liste
doit recueillir au moins 10% des
suffrages exprimés
celles ayant obtenu au moins 5 % peuvent
fusionner avec celle qui se maintiennent
le scrutin et régionales mais la liste
déposée présente les candidats par
section départementale c'est à dire
concrètement qu'un électeur yvelinois et
un électeur estoniens qui appartiennent
à la même région voteront pour des
candidats différents
mais une tête de liste est désigné pour
l'ensemble de la région le nombre de
sièges attribués à chaque liste est
calculé au niveau de la région
mais au sein de chaque liste les sièges
sont attribués par sections
départementales
prenons un exemple si la liste d'un
candidat arrive en tête au niveau
régional alors ses conseillers régionaux
obtiendront des sièges en fonction des
suffrages obtenus dans chaque
département pour la région ile de france
ils sont onze candidats à se présenter
les listes doivent être paritaires il
doit y avoir autant d'hommes et de
femmes sur la même liste
retour à la campagne après ces
explications avec la présentation du
programme de la présidente sortante
valérie pécresse elle s'est exprimée à
la semaine dernière sur ses priorités
sur les financements prévus
parmi les points importants la tolérance
zéro face aux violences la relance des
entreprises et de l'emploi l'acte ii
aussi de la révolution des transports
elle met aussi l'écologie et la lutte
contre les fractures sociales et
l'égalité des chances cedec est
entièrement financé il sera mis en
oeuvre sans augmentation d'impôts et
sans augmentation de la neige tout les
mesures nouvelles seront financés par la
dynamique de nos recettes intrinsèque et
par les économistes nous allons faire
sur nos dépenses de fonctionnement à
raison de 400 millions d'euros
d'économies par an et fonctionnement 2
milliards 4 sur le mandat qui
financeront nos nouvelles priorités
parmi les différentes propositions on
notera l'effacement de la dette qu'ovide
pour les 7000 tpe et pme franciliennes
le bouclier tarifaire également pour les
transports en commun avec un maximum de
4 euros pour tous déplacements sur le
réseau francilien ou encore un objectif
de 100 % des communes sans pesticides ni
perturbateurs endocriniens et aussi à la
création d'une agence pour l'orientation
des jeunes la lutte contre le décrochage
scolaire et le combat contre les
discriminations
[Musique]
on passe à la campagne pour les
départementales à présent direction le
canton de montigny le bretonneux cinq
binômes se présenter une fois encore les
maires des deux principales communes
sont engagés montigny le bretonneux
guyancourt de communes regroupées depuis
1991 au sein du canton de montigny le
bretonneux pour un total de soixante
deux mille habitants dont moins de la
moitié sont électeurs lors du scrutin
départemental il n'est pas rare de voir
les maires des deux villes s'affronter
ainsi en 2008 françois de ligne et maire
de lui en cours l'emportait face à
michel laugier maire de montigny le
bretonneux un scénario inverse à celui
de 2015 soulignant qu'il s'agissait
également de la première élection d'un
binôme michel laugier l'emportant avec
laurence trochut cette année les élus
départementaux ne se représente pas à ce
scrutin inédit donc mais qui voit
s'affronter à nouveau les maires de ces
deux villes à gauche françois morton
maire de guyancourt se présente avec
claire l'avenant tandis qu'au centre
droit laurent merckaert maire de
montigny le bretonneux se présente avec
laurence boulard and on a à la fois le
programme qui porte sur l'ensemble du
département et qui est composée de 21
points dans toutes les thématiques qui
recouvre les les délégations et les
missions du département
et puis sur le canton de montigny et
guyancourt il y a plus particulièrement
aux points
le département a des compétences ce sont
des compétences que nous portons avec
nos valeurs et nos convictions
donc on est en capacité de vous proposer
une alternative une alternative fort
pour remettre effectivement le
département au top ces compétences
directeur de cabinet du maire de
montigny le bretonneux pendant 19 ans
avant d'en devenir lui même le premier
élu l'an dernier alors un merckaert
espère maintenant leur succéder au sein
de l'assemblée départementale
j'ai une connaissance des dossiers du
territoire aussi importante et des
personnes aussi des interlocuteurs des
différents partenaires et que dans le
cadre de ma fonction de maire et de ma
délégation à l'aménagement et
l'urbanisme à l'agglomération
ça me semblait judicieux de pouvoir
mettre cette expérience au profit du
département afin de cinquième sur la
liste victorieuse aux municipales en
2014 avant de devenir maire en 2019
après la démission de marie christine le
tarnec à guyancourt françois morton est
aujourd'hui bien installé dans sa
commune il veut fédérer les forces de
gauche dans leur ensemble nous avons
fait le choix et nous l'avons
dès le début que nous ne souhaitions pas
avoir tous les logo possibles et
imaginables sur nos affiches parce que
nous sommes de candidature citoyenne je
ne veux pas faire croire que j'adhère au
parti socialiste alors que ça n'est pas
vrai
claire ne veux pas faire croire qu'elles
adhèrent à europe ecologie les verts
alors que ça n'est pas vrai voilà c'est
une réalité
c'est une candidature dans la sincérité
les choses sont très claires on rejette
pas les parties on en a besoin j'en suis
convaincu j'ai moi-même été adhérent
d'un parti politique par le passé je
fais le choix en ce moment de que ce ne
soit pas le cas
deux autres listes se présentent sur ce
canton de montigny le bretonneux le
binôme lrm de collines bécamel et
grégory pape et le binôme du
rassemblement national d'aurore du fayet
de la tour et de gaëtan bros et ce sont
donc bien quatre listes qui se
présentent autres cantons celui de
bonnières sur seine avec également
quatre listes et le conflit
droite-gauche qui se joua notamment
entre deux figures nationales patrick
stefanini homme fort est des
républicains et pierre krasucki l'ancien
le fils de l'ancien président
emblématique de la cgt portraits croisés
signé nicolas d'andry il a mené la
victoire de jacques chirac pour la
présidentielle de 1995 et celle de
valérie pécresse pour les régionales de
on le surnomme du coup le faiseur de roi
aujourd'hui patrick stefanini et
candidat au départemental dans les
yvelines
il est en binôme avec josette gens dans
le canton de bonnières-sur-seine 50 ans
typiquement rural avec beaucoup de
petites communes des communes qui ont
moins de 1000 habitants
nous sommes dans un canton où il faut
beaucoup travailler sur les questions de
mobilité gestion des collèges
problématique des transports questions
de sécurité en zone rurale différents
points du programme du candidat du
groupe ensemble pour les yvelines
diplômé de l'ena en 1979 patrick
stefanini a occupé plusieurs postes dans
la haute fonction publique
il a aussi été préfet dans plusieurs
départements aujourd'hui il mène sa
campagne notamment auprès des maires du
canton merci beaucoup monsieur le maire
aura comme préfet j'ai servi notamment
à clermont ferrand dans le département
du puy-de-dôme j'ai servi à bordeaux
dans le département de la gironde
j'ai l'habitude de la relation avec les
maires et moi je mettrai au service de
notre binôme et à partir de là au
service de l'ensemble des maires et donc
de tous les habitants du canton
je mettrai mon expérience de l'état et
mon expérience de la région puisque j'ai
dirigé pendant plus d'un an les services
de la région du côté de
bonnières-sur-seine la gauche avec
notamment le parti communiste français
aura un binôme avec héloïse venancio et
pierre krasucki ce dernier est le fils
d'henri krasucki secrétaire général de
la cgt de 1982 à 1992 il a aussi été
membre de la résistance pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale est envoyé en
camp de déportation sur le but de
beethoven là vous voyez là sur la halle
et on vous dit disque bah c'est ce qu'il
avait dans sa salle à manger
il était fou amoureux il adorait
beethoven à noël en 43 il s'est mis à
siffler la septième symphonie de
beethoven qui leur faisait tenir parce
que psychologiquement fallait tenir
pierre krasucki conserve aujourd'hui
tous les rites elle de l'engagement
politique de son père la volonté de
faire quelque chose pour défendre les
gens assad à des injustices comme elles
se produisent à travers les politiques
mises en place depuis maintenant pour
madère panda 2 pendant la décennie j'ai
milité pendant près de 40 ans dans mon
entreprise et j'ai assumé toutes les
responsabilités de secrétaire d'un
syndicat en passant par délégué syndical
élu c'est l'élu c'est un an représentant
csc hss est finie délégation des
personnels
toujours militant de la cgt pour les
retraités reste engagé au parti
communiste français
c'est sous cette couleur qu'il souhaite
proposer une alternance autour d'une
union de la gauche aux élections
départementales avec plusieurs
propositions notamment autour de
l'environnement la santé la solidarité
envers les personnes âgées mais aussi la
jeunesse il ya actuellement une
plateforme d'e
monopoly si je puis dire le système
scolaire c'est celui des je crois et
c'est me dit bon bah et c'est une
gestion privée or nous le privé on n'en
veut pas on veut une gestion publique
si son engagement et plus syndical
pierre razoux qui a une expérience des
campagnes électorales
il a notamment était déjà candidat pour
une élection cantonale et suppléant lors
des élections législatives de 2012 sur
le canton ne mord pas seulement trois
listes sont engagées celle de la
majorité sortante divers droite celle du
rassemblement national et celle de la
gauche unie menée par tristan jacques et
béatrice pierrât nous avons interrogés
ces derniers sur leur programme
[Musique]
je pense qu'il faut art nouveau en
politique
aujourd'hui on a des politiciens qui
font ça par métier pour moi la politique
c'est d'abord un mandat et c'est
important d'avoir un pied dans la
société civile quand on fait de la
politique pour effectivement renouveler
la vie politique
idy noise puisque actuellement il ya
100% de des lieux départementaux qui
appartiennent en majorité et nous semble
important d'apporter une voie différente
pour qu'il puisse avoir une contrôle de
l'action départementale et un
contradicteur
alors à des enjeux de notre canton
concerne la circulation des personnes
nous sommes dans un canton qui est à la
fois rural et urbain avec des
problématiques de circulation qui sont
différentes notamment dans la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux des gros sujets
liés à la circulation sur la rd 91 la
rd36 est également nous souhaitons
mettre en place un système de transport
à la demande pour les zones plus rurales
pour interconnecter les habitantes et
les habitants avec des transports en
commun principal axe de campagne et bien
sûr l'action sociale que la première
compétence du département
le département des yvelines est un des
plus riches de france
son budget alloué à l'action sociale et
95e de france il me paraît vraiment
important de de remettre le la
solidarité au coeur de l'action
départementale en augmentant le rsa
et en l'ouvrant aux jeunes de 18 à 25
ans et en augmentant aussi l'aide
sociale à l'enfance qui est bien
inférieur à la moyenne régionale des au
département propos recueillis par
mélanie poké bixente mais rien senti
steban bonjour la rédaction téléphiles
vous m'avez rejoint en plateau pour
parler cumul des mandats dans ces
élections qui vont se tenir les 20 et 27
juin on remarque plusieurs candidats
sont à la fois présents sur les listes
des régionales ils sont aussi candidats
en binôme pour les départementales
certains ont déjà des postes de maires
aussi on va essayer d'y voir plus clair
avec vous on va commencer par un rappel
historique d'abord en 2012 90% des
députés et 77% des sénateurs cumuler des
mandats vous parlait alors d'une
exception française vis-à-vis de
l'europe et même d'une culture du cumul
en 2014 de lois sont promulguées
dorénavant un député ou un sénateur ne
peuvent plus être maire président ou
vice-président de toutes les instances
locales
on va prendre un cas concret celui de
philippe benassaya il est député il est
candidat ou départementale sur le canton
de bois d'arcy et il ne pourra pas en
cas de victoire prétendants la
présidence du département
est ce qu'il y à d'autres préconisations
de ce type pour les élections oui pour
faire simple dans le cas des
législatives et des départementales
on ne peut pas cumuler plus de deux
postes soit un candidat est élu en tant
que conseiller départemental ou régional
et dans ce cas la règle et qui peut
avoir un autre mandat nationale comme
député député européen ou sénateurs ou
encore un autre mandat local comme maire
ou conseiller municipal autre subtilité
un candidat peut se présenter et être
élu au département et à la région à la
fois à condition qu'il n'occupe pas
d'autres délégations nassau territoriale
donc un président de département ne peut
pas être aussi président de région c'est
ça et les représentants de ces deux
fonctions ne peuvent pas non plus être
maire député ou sénateur
par contre il est possible de cumuler
une présidence départementale ou
régionale avec un mandat de conseiller
d'une autre échelle territoriale dont la
loi a évolué ces dernières années est ce
que d'autres évolutions sont encore à
l'étude un projet est effectivement en
cours de réflexion il pourrait interdire
aux parlementaires et aux responsables
locaux d'exercer un quatrième mandat
consécutif et ce afin de favoriser le
renouvellement de la classe politique
ça ne concerne pas directement le
département des yvelines ni même
l'ile-de-france mesquin
ministre on peut imaginer un ministre
président d'une région où d'un
département légalement oui c'est
possible mais dans la pratique en
revanche les gouvernements l'interdisent
de fait une décision qui remonte à 1997
avec le premier ministre lionel jospin
merci beaucoup bixente pour ces
précisions concernant le cumul des
mandats c'est la fin de ce set 8
politique de ce journal des campagnes
régionales et départementales dernier un
numéro avant le premier tour du scrutin
ce sera mercredi prochain sur tv 78è
d'ici là très bonne semaine
[Musique]